اريدك تامرهم في بلادنا ننبهم
ننبهم على
ان يصدقوا القانون
العراقي نعم وهم اجانب ومحتلين وغزال
من كبد الضباب ظهرت رساله غامضه وصادمه
تقول لا تنجرف وراء استفزازات اللصوص فهم
يستدرجونك للوحل هكذا قالها بوتين لصديقه
المقرب من العرب وصاحب رابع اقوى جيش في
العالم
في حامل الرساله ليقول له
نحن لن نخضع مهما حدث وسنقاتل وحدنا واما
ان ننتصر او نموت بكبرياء نعم هكذا قالها
صدام حسين لبوتين وبتلك الطاوله المستديره
اجتمعت امريكا بحلف الناتو محددين اهدافهم
في الجسد العراقي بينما العرب يطبقون
مسرحيه الثور الاسود ليصفق من خلف الستار
الجيش الامريكي معلنا عن بدايه غزوه
للعراق ما هي الرساله التي ارسلها بوتر
لصدام حسين قبل الغزو الامريكي بشهر واحد
وما هو سلاح امريكا الخبيث الذي استعملته
في هذه الحرب ولماذا تغضب بوتين عن غزو
العراق رغم انه كان اشد المعارضين للغزو
وهل باع بوتين العراق لامريكا ام ان للامر
وجها اخر مظلم لا يعرفه الكثيرون لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه
رساله صادمه قبل احتلال القوات الامريكيه
العراق عام 2003 كان المناخ خصبا للوقيعه
بين الروس وحلفائهم العرب الجميع يتخبطون
في الازمه بين صدام حسين وجرجس
والشك يطال الجميع واشنطن تلقي بقنبله
نفسيه لتوقع بين صدام واهم حلفائه فقبل
احتلال العراق بشهر واحد وصل رئيس الوزراء
الروسي يافدين بريماكوف الى بغداد محملا
برساله شفاهيه من فلاديمير بوتين الى صدام
حسين كانت الرساله غامضه وفي توقيت غريب
فما الذي شاء بك يبرمكوف وفي هذا التوقيت
بالذات حاول البعض معرفه فحوى الرساله
التي يحملها مبعوث موسكو ولكن دون جدوى
فقد اصر بريماكوف على مقابله صدام اولا
وابلاغه الرساله بنفسه تم تحديد موعد
المقابله وجلس صدام امام الوزير الروسي
وهنا كانت الصدمه فقد قال بريماكوف سيدي
الرئيس من اجل انقاذ الموقف نقترح على
سيادتكم التنحي عن الحكم وانتجر انتخابات
رئاسيه عامه حره ونزيهه على ان تبقى انت
في موقع قيادي سياسي مهم وان تتوجه الى
الشعب الامريكي برساله تطمين بانه ليس
للعراق اي نوايا شريره تجاه امريكا هذه
الرساله اكدت لصدام انه سيواجه الغول
الامريكي وحيدا وان روسيا لن تدعم العراق
في حربه الكبرى فكيف كان رد صدام
رهان الغزو
تلقى صدام حسين الصدمه الروسيه برباطه جاش
وهدوء شديد وظن المبعوث الروسي ان الرئيس
العراقي سيقتنع بمقترحاته ويتراجع من اجل
انقاذ الموقع خصوصا وان الرساله الروسيه
تؤكد ان موسكو لن تستطيع التدخل في الازمه
لصالح بغداد ولكن ما حدث كان عكس ما توقعه
مبعوث موسكو تماما بمجرد ان انهى بريما
كوف حديثه طلب صدام حضور اعضاء القياده
العراقيه وانضمامهم للاجتماع فارق عزيز
وسعدون حمادي وعبد الحميد محمود التريكي
وبعد ان حضروا رد صدام رساله موسكو قائلا
هذه رساله امريكيه صهيونيه انتم تخذلونني
الان مره اخرى كما خذلتموني امام
الامريكان عام 91 نحن سنقاتل سنقاتل
سنقاتل حاول الرسل انقاذ الموقف ولكن يبدو
ان اسد الرافدين كان قد حسم قراره فاما
النصر على الامريكان واما الموت بكرامه
وكبرياء ولكن ما علاقه زياره بريماكوف
لبغداد بقنبله واشنطن النفسيه سلاح امريكا
الخبيث جاءت رساله موسكو لصدام بعد اتفاق
مع واشنطن على انها محاوله لاقناع الرئيس
العراقي بالتناحي وتفادي الحرب وبالتالي
فتلك الرساله لم تكن سوى محاوله من الروس
للوساطه وانقاذ العراق من براثن الغول
الامريكي ولكن
استغلت الموقف في الواقيعه بين بوتين
وحلفائه ومحاوله اظهار الدب الروسي بمظهر
ضبع غادر فانتشرت اخبار تقول ان موسكو قد
باعت صدام وقبضت الثمن مليارات الدولارات
من بعض دول الخليج كالسعوديه والامارات
والكويت ونصف تلك المبالغ الضخمه كان
عباره عن عقود تجاريه تصب في صالح روسيا
بل ولم تكتفي موسكو بذلك فقد عرضت
الاشتراك في العمليات العسكريه ضد العراق
ولكن بشروط تضمن لها ان عاش اقتصادها ودعم
السلع التي تنتجها وتسويقها في السوق
الامريكيه والاوروبيه وكان هذا هو ثمن
تغاضي بوتين عن احتلال امريكا للعراق ولكن
ما الدليل على كل هذا تلك الاخبار لم تذكر
في اي مصادر موثوقه ومصدرها الوحيد هو
اعلام واشنطن كما انه اذا كان لبوتين قد
باع العراق لامريكا فلماذا منعت واشنطن
شركه النفط الروسيه مثل شركه لوك من
الاستثمار في النفط العراقي ووضعتها في
القائمه السوداء بعد الحرب ما السر وراء
محاوله اظهار موسكو بانها باعت حليفها
الامر مفهوم تماما يا عزيزي فانتشار اخبار
كهذه كفيل بان يدمر العلاقات بين الدب
الروسي وحلفائه العرب وغير العرب بعد
اظهاره بموقف الضبع الشارد خصوصا وان في
ذلك التوقيت كان بوتين يعمل على عوده
روسيا كقوه عظمى وقطب عالمي من جديد هل
علمت الان حجم الخطر الذي كانت تشعر به
امريكا ولكن ان لم يكن في الامر مصلحه
لروسيا فلماذا تغاضت عن احتلال امريكا
للعراق رغم انها كانت اقوى حليف لها في
المنطقه بالعوده الى تلك الفطره اي بدايه
الالفيه الثالثه سنجد ان الدب الروسي كان
جريحا وعليه ان يضمد جراحه قبل ان يقف
ويدخل في اي معركه فمنذ انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي اواخر عام 91 كان الشغل الشاغل
لروسيا هو لملمه شؤونها الداخليه وما زاد
الطين بيله ان فتره رئاسه لم تدفع البلاد
لاي خطوه للامام لياتي بعد ذلك الرئيس
الروسي الحالي فلاديمير بوتين حاملا حلم
عوده روسيا المرعبه مره اخرى واعاد ترتيب
اوراقه واضعا البلاد على اولى درجات السلم
التقدم نحن لا نلمع روسيا ولسنا في صفها
ولن ننسى دماء المواطنين السوريين ولنضع
خطا تحت المواطنين السوريين الابرياء التي
هدرت دون العسكريين من اي فئه كانوا اذا
هيا لنعد الى كبد الحديث وبرغم كل ما فعله
بوتين الا انه في وقت غزو العراق لم تكن
روسيا قد استعادت قوتها بعد وبالتالي لم
يكن بمقدورها ان تواجه امريكا العسكريه
سبب اخر جعل روسيا تتغاضى عن غزو العراق
وهو ان بوتين كان يرى ان الغزو الامريكي
للعراق سوف يصب في مصلحته فعرق صدام كان
صاحب رابع اقوى جيش في العالم كما ان
النسبه الكبرى من العراقيين يرفضون التدخل
الامريكي رفضا قاطعا لذا فان العراق قد
يتحول الى مستنقع او بركه من الوحل تنغرس
فيه اقدام الغول الامريكي وربما تحوله
المقاومه العراقيه الى مقبره للطموح
الامريكي في المنطقه ككل ولكن هل كانت
امريكا لتتراجع عن احتلال العراق تحت اي
ظرف
العراق هدف امريكا الحقيقي
يبدو ان العراق كان هو الهدف الامريكي
الحقيقي الذي ارادت واشنطن ان تعمي اعين
الجميع عنه حيث ان حربها ضد افغانستان عام
2001 كان الهدف النهائيا منها هو العراق
ففي لقاء عام 2013 مع قناه روسيه قال
فلاديميرتي اخر سفراء روسيا لدى العراق
قبل الغزو الامريكي بعد احداث الحادي عشر
من سبتمبر عام 2001 شاركت ضمن فريق من
الخبراء في اجتماع مغلق مع وفد امريكي
اجتمعنا من اجل مناقشه اوضاع العراق
الاقتصاديه ولكن تحول الاجتماع الى محضر
استجواب لنا من قبل عناصر استخباراتيه
امريكيه وكان اهم شيء بالنسبه لهم معرفه
مدى جاهزيه العراق للتصدي لحرب شامله ولكن
يبدو ان تصريحات قد اغضبت البعض فقد تم
حذفها تماما من القناه الروسيه بعد وقت
قليل من اللقاء
بوتين يهاجم لم تنسى موسكو البلطجه
الامريكيه في غزو العراق ولم يمر الامر
عليها مرور الكرام ففي احد اللقاءات قال
بوتين عن غزو امريكا للعراق تحت اي ذريعه
دخل الامريكان العراق تحدثوا عن تطوير
اسلحه الدمار الشامل دخلوا ودمروا البلاد
واوجدوا بؤره للارهاب الدولي ثم تبين انه
مخطو فقالوا المخاب رات خذلتنا وبسخريه
قال
هذا رائع دمر البلاد المخابرات خذلتهم
وهذا كل التبرير لديهم وتضح انه لم يكن
هناك اي اسلحه وبعد اقل عام واحد على
اعدام صدام وقف بوتين قائلا قبل فتره
قصيره نفذ حكم الاعدام في صدام حسين لا
اريد التعليق على هذا الامر تحديدا لكنني
اتساءل باي تهمه اداه هل بتهمه الانتقام
من قريه شيعيه واعدام حوالي 147 شخصا من
سكانها اراد بوتين فطحل الجرائم الامريكيه
التي راح ضحيتها مئات الالاف من العراقيين
بحجه تخليصهم من الديكتاتور اراد بوتين ان
يعود بالزمن الى الوراء ويقف بجانب صدام
حسين وينقذ العراق ولكن الزمن لا يعود
للوراء ابدا وليست كل الاخطاء يمكن
اصلاحها بالندى والان هل تعتقد ان معادله
القوى قد تغيرت وان بوتين سيسحب البساطه
من تحت اقدام امريكا وان حدث ذلك هل سيكون
للعرب على موعد اخر مع صدام اخر
[موسيقى]